We're a family.
Me, a boy,
and his mom,
who is usually great,
but occasionally murders
people with her bare hands.
What could go wrong?
Don't get me wrong.
This isn't some
German fairy tale
where a witch keeps me
locked up
till it's time to eat me.
Love is nice,
giving.
I wolf you.
I fell in love with
a certain version of her.
We…
both…
have done bad things.
I wanted to move here
so that we could start new,
be safe,
and never have to do
anything bad ever again.
We get to choose.
We are safe now.
We're together.
I promise, no more.
No more bad things.
So what brings you in?
We had a fight.
Love, I told you,
nothing happened.
If anything,
she came on to me.
You kept a box, Joe.
I know what that means.
I know you.
Why don't you
love me anymore?
You know why,
you just won't say it.
I don't know
what you're talking about.
You had a fucking hook
to my throat.
And then,
I said I was pregnant,
and then, we just
went on and pretended
like it didn't happen.
No, no! No, we didn't!
No, we didn't.
Is there something else
you're not telling me?
OK. He… He kissed me.
-He kissed you?
-Yeah.
It was before
he left for school.
I mean, obviously,
I shut it down.
-That's shutting it down?
-Don't yell at me.
You have been
sneaking around.
Sneaking around?
That's crazy.
You made me feel
like there's something
wrong with me,
and I've done everything
you asked
when you've been lying to me
this whole time.
Right now, my game
is being a good husband.
No, no.
No, the best husband,
so Love doesn't
get suspicious
about what's
really going on:
that I can't stop
thinking about you,
Marienne.
My wife needs to feel
like mildly transgressing
with that idiot rich kid
did the trick.
She's not a boring,
tired suburban mom.
She's fun, wild,
still the Love Quinn
who flirts with strangers
in the produce section.
What, you act like I…
I'm not all in.
I am right here.
All I do is worry about you.
I don't need you
to worry about me.
I need your heart.
-Henry needs your heart.
-Leave Henry out of this.
I can't, Joe.
Unlike you,
I have to be his mother,
24-7,
in addition to running
a fucking business,
keeping this house together,
dragging you to therapy,
trying to be my sexiest self
so you don't get bored
and find another Natalie.
Can you please
lower your voice?
Why?
You hate hearing the truth?
Our marriage
is completely one-sided.
That is absurd.
You made me kill her.
In addition to being mother
of the fucking year,
I had to run interference
on one of your
fucking patterns.
-I killed Natalie for you!
-Shut up!
Did you ever
actually love me?
From the moment I saw you.
You know this. I would do--
I know
that you cheated on me.
-And you lied.
-Okay. Can… Can we?
You made me feel
like you really saw me.
Yeah, he's just a kid
who you were having
an affair with.
We can do this
if you are willing to admit,
you have not been
perfectly happy either.
We have both
made mistakes.
I tried, and I know that
you have been trying too,
but it didn't work.
And now, we can be honest
about that
and deal with this
like two adults.
Meaning what?
Meaning we don't have
to do anything impulsive.
What does that mean?
James.
James, what you did to him…
I did.
I did kill him,
but I didn't mean to.
It was my first time
using it, and…
the dosage was too high
when ingested.
This time, I'm letting it
absorb through the skin.
None of this
would be happening
if you hadn't grabbed
a weapon.
No one will ever love you
like I do, Joe.
But that…
that little voice
in the back of my head
that I've been suppressing
this whole fucking time,
it was right.
I'm not the problem.
My husband is the problem.
Aconite, when
injected directly, burns
as it moves through
the system to the heart.
Think less slow paralysis,
more total fucking agony.
I'm sorry
it had to come to this.
Did you really think
that I wouldn't start
to wonder…
what you were growing
in the garden?
Wolfsbane, a paralytic.
-No.
-It's slows the heart.
So, I Googled antidotes.
Turns out, I needed
biohacking. Adrenaline.
And who doesn't have that
around here, right?
A little voice in my head
told me to take it…
before you played your hand.
Joe…
You did this to yourself.
And the hardest part
was making the dose,
because I couldn't lie
to myself.
It had to be enough.
I had to finally stop you.
We're perfect
for each other…
but bad…
for Henry.
He'll know
what you are.